en public sénat et le centre national du
livre présente livres et vous
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous quel plaisir
de vous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro
de livres et vous qui va aujourd'hui
tourner le regard vers la gauche ou ce
qu'il en reste
quelques semaines après le départ
d'emmanuel morel chef de l'ailé gauche
du parti socialiste qui estimait que son
parti n'était plus en phase avec sa
conception du socialisme mais le parti
socialiste n'ayant pas le monopole de la
gauche
comment la définir sont là clivé peut-on
la définir autrement que comme au lieu
d'une contestation ou d'une résistance
qui ne s'entend pas toujours sur le
choix des armes à adopter pour mener le
combat
c'est à cette question que nous allons
tenter de répondre aujourd'hui avec
l'historien et théoricien politique de
la gauche pierre rosanvallon qui fait
paraître notre histoire intellectuelle
et politique de 1968 à 2018 c'est le
bilan d'un demi siècle d'évolution de la
gauche française qui paraît aux éditions
du seuil
il nous rejoindra en deuxième partie
après avoir accueilli mon première
invitée aujourd'hui écrivain scénariste
critique engagé qui fait paraître aux
éditions verticales son dernier livre en
guerre bon jean françois bégaudeau
bonjour en guerre c'est un appel ou un
constat c'est un constat justement le il
faut pas entendre en guerre danse libre
comme comment dire le un appel à faire
la guerre ou la mise en scène de
personnages qui serait particulièrement
guerrier je crois que c'est pas le cas
de mes personnages principaux à une
exception près louisa qui à un moment se
mettent en guerre explicitement non
c'est plutôt de prendre acte d'un état
de guerre permanent un état de guerre
structurelles qu'on appelle la guerre
sociale dans une certaine tradition
intellectuelle à laquelle j'adhère me
lie à une conflictuelle it et pour le
dire plus modérément
parce que je pense que d'un titre comme
en guerre et un peu spectaculaire je
veux bien le confesser donc le vrai mot
c'est la conflictualité la confiture dit
et social structure une société voilà ce
qui pourrait être une conviction je
dirais matricielle de la gauche par
exemple pour aller dans le sens de votre
émission mais en guerre c'est aussi ce
que prononce manuel valls au lendemain
des attentats du bataclan en novembre
2015 il dit nous sommes en guerre et
cette fois ci il fait référence à la
guerre que les djihadistes man contre
l'état français
vous vous parlez de gars social c'est
pas la même gare évidemment que c'est
pas la même
il est évident que je pense que le
pouvoir tout ce qui émane du pouvoir et
quand même a rarement se caractérise
rarement par une intelligence
exceptionnelle en tout cas par une
rigueur intellectuelle
formidable ce sont des incantations le
pouvoir des livres des miennes et
gestion des incantations
il peut y avoir des gens intelligents
pouvoir et par exemple manuel valls est
absolument quelqu'un d'intelligent mais
en tant qu'il est au pouvoir et parlant
depuis le pouvoir lors la ce moment là
il est effectivement à betty il est à
betty par cet exercice là et à ce moment
il est habité par sa fonction et d'avoir
dit à ce moment là qu'ils vont que nous
étions en guerre est une faute
intellectuelle majeure intellectuelle
est une faute intellectuelle majeure au
sens où je pense que la rigueur
intellectuelle et c'est d'articuler la
pensée à un état du réel alors là il
était évident que nous n'étions pas d'un
point de vue réaliste du point de vue de
l'examen réel des choses nous n'étions
pas en guerre en plus une formule
particulièrement obscène par rapport à
tous les théâtres d'opérations qui au
même moment étaient craquelés en
internat du bataclan après les led les
dizaines des centaines de morts qu'il ya
eu c'est un geste belliqueux l égard de
l'état français c'était sans doute un
geste belliqueux à la guerre de l'état
français il a été très peu suivie
d'effet donc une guerre c'est quelque
chose qui s'installe dans la durée
je suis parisien j'ai été assez proche
des attentats physiquement je ne me suis
pas senti en guerre aucun mordant mais
passons sur ces choses qui sont qui
n'est pas l'attention bien sûr et puis
je pense que c'était aussi une stratégie
de la part de manuel valls ou d'autres
de situer la guerre de ce côté là une
espèce de guerre de civilisation
culturelle identitaire je vois là on
peut l'appeler de la manière pour
masquer pour masquer la guerre sociale
et la convivialité sociale alors la
guerre sociale qu'est ce que ça c'est la
lutte des classes oui mais la lutte des
classes au sens où marx longtemps et je
pense qu'on fait souvent un contre sens
sur la façon dont marx entendait la
lutte des classes la lutte des classes
n'est pas justement les classes
populaires qui s'arme pour mener une
lutte contre les dominants ça c'est un
aspect de la lutte des classes très
minoritaire dans l'histoire d'ailleurs
très très peu fréquent hélas non
la lutte des classes est un état du
monde c'est un état structurelle du
monde qui fait qu'effectivement le réel
social est structurée par notamment une
classe dominante
qui lutte en permanence pour ses propres
intérêts en fait la lutte des classes et
surtout les dominants qui l'amène heures
pour ils ont des intérêts à préserver
ceux qui possèdent des choses les
propriétaires ceux qui possèdent une
petite production par exemple pour
prendre une norme très très marxiste et
est donc ces gens là s'activent en
permanence pour conserver leurs intérêts
je crois que c'est un des aspects de la
théorie de la lutte des classes selon
marx mais effectivement on a retenu plus
tôt le second aspect qui est à dire
effectivement armons nous luttons
luttons pour l'émancipation allons
arracher avec les dans un certain nombre
de progrès sociaux à la classe dominante
qui veut pas les octroyée il ya cet
aspect là mais comme je trouve que
l'autre aspect est assez peu mis en
avant c'est celui que j'ai eu envie
envie de mettre en avant la aujourd'hui
conformément à votre question dans ce
roman en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est
très présent c'est un roman qu'on
pourrait enfin l'écriture de votre de
votre roman vise à l'efficacité
sociologique vous présenter les
personnages d'abord par leur trajectoire
pour aller pour se rendre au travail à
une dimension géographique extrêmement
sociologique aussi on sait d'où ils
viennent leur lieu de naissance ils sont
quasiment caricaturer pour vous écrire
ce roman là est ce que c'était une
manière de une forme d'engagement
politique pour 10 mais voilà la
littérature que aussi m'aider a affirmé
mme engagés dans la direction que je
souhaite qu est ce que ça c'est un
travail de deux styles faire un roman
social ça peut être aussi intéressant
juste pour le style c'est exactement un
travail de style mais je pense que quand
on est un littéraire et qu'on écrit des
livres qui ont la grande prétention
d'être de la littérature
il est évident que notre premier souci
n'est pas du tout de se dire j'aimerais
bien faire un livre utile pour les gens
et donc faire un truc engagé moi c'est
absolument pas comme ça que je
réfléchisse quand je me lance dans un
livre je me lance dans un livre quand je
trouve que ça va être intéressant pour
la littérature et je trouvais qu'il
était intéressant de faire d'abord une
carte sociale du monde contemporain bon
à mon échelle à moi et de se demander à
travers tout un tas de situations très
précises et très concrètes dans quelle
mesure jusqu'à quel point nous sommes
des sujets sociaux jusqu'à quel point
nous sommes à j par la machine sociale
et ça ça vaudrait pour mon personnage de
prolétaires louisa ça vaudrait pour mon
petit bourgeois qui est romain ça
vaudrait pour mon ouvrier qui est
cristiano ça vaut ça vaudrait aussi pour
catherine tendront la direccte
humaine qui elle aussi l'état j elle
aussi est un sujet social elle aussi
elle est activée par toute une idéologie
presque malgré elle qui passe par elle
qui en gros une idéologie managériale
qu'on commence à bien connaître puisque
maintenant elle est au pouvoir en france
donc c'était c'était ça la question et
c'était d'aller faire de la sociologie
fine ne sorte qu' on puisse voir dans le
moindre des gestes quotidiens à quel
point est bien ce geste est très
largement conditionnée par des
stimulations social nous et essayer de
montrer le fatalisme qui lie à l'oeuvre
la détermination qui a l'air dans
chacune de ses trajectoires le montrer
l'observer le constater le déplier vous
disiez que les personnages étaient
peut-être un peu caricaturaux vous avez
utilisé un mot un peu approchant moi je
crois pas je crois qu'un d'abord un
archétype social s'est toujours remarqué
mais vous dites vous-même mon ouvrier
mon personnage gimont ouvriers c'est mon
plan de travail de départ quand je mets
cristiano deux points mon ouvrier ça je
le mets dans mon petit document word de
travail et puis après à 300 pages après
il ya cristiano il ya un vrai personnage
un personnage qui est un immigré
portugais
il est fils de plombier il a travaillé
dans une usine 18 ans pas 30 pas 12
sa mère est dépressive il est très
nerveux il écoute du métal oui là est un
personnage qui commence à se constituer
est l'archétype devient une personne
devient un individu mais je crois quand
même que malgré ça même si on arrive à
la singularité d'un individu alors on
n'échappera pas au fait qu'il est quand
même toujours le produit d'un certain
nombre de détermination c'est là où la
distinction vous faites entre d'un côté
un engagement politique et votre travail
d'écrivain peut-être ne tient pas
jusqu'au bout parce que ce que vous
écrivez est complètement innervé parce
que vous semblez penser par ailleurs je
pense qu'on a un tempérament moi je
crois qu'on a si vous voulez les
convictions qu'on actions politiques
sont très largement elle ressortie c'est
un tempérament
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut vraiment
comprendre et vous c'est un tempérament
de gauche par exemple vraiment de gauche
qui est évidemment le produit moi même
je suis multi déterminer je suis au
croisement incertain de détermination
éducative de milieux climatique
peut-être vous parlez de vos
détermination les connais pas vraiment
vos personnages sont extrêmement brossé
de manière très précis sociologiquement
bon c'est pas trop français à belle cote
alors je vous renvoie un livre que j'ai
fait et voilà où je disais tout qui
s'appelle de singe ma vie politique
justement j'essayais de faire une
généalogie de mes idées politiques et de
montrer à quel point il ya une formation
des idées les idées sont des faits les
idées sont des choses matérielles et
elles sont formées matériellement les
idées
donc je le jeu m'ont très bien quel
point j'étais presque programmé pour
penser dans le champ intellectuel enfin
diront dans le domaine de penser dans
lequel j'essaie de penser donc ce
tempérament s'il voulait il est
évidemment là quand vous écrivez des
livres vous faites vous faites aussi des
romans avec votre tempérament et donc
forcément que mécaniquement se disent on
may affect politique on va les appeler
comme ça vont imprégné aussi ma
littérature mais c'est pas une intention
c'est pas une intention de faire un
livre qui démontrerait à quel point
c'est génial d'être de gauche avec quel
point il faut absolument s'orienter vers
ces idées là au contraire je pense qu'il
ya par exemple dans la guerre tout un
tas d'éléments qui crispe qui pourraient
crispé la gauche qui pourrait la réduire
d'ailleurs il quelques critiques venant
de la gauche fait à ce livre pour disons
que d'une certaine manière il servait
pas la cause parce que oui
quand j'écris un livre g7 servir à cause
de la littérature et s'il ya des choses
qui coince dans mes personnages par
rapport à ce que serait une espèce comme
ça de penser auto-réalisatrice delà de
la gauche
eh bien je préférerai toujours la
complexité à ce qui sert la cause donc
par exemple
louisa may prolétaires c'est comme ça
que je me je me la raconter vous lisez
bien le fils travaille ça est une petite
libéral sur pattes
louisa n'est pas là trop l'eau que rêve
la gauche hélas elle n'est pas à
conscientiser la gauche elle ne
manifeste pas elle n'a aucune culture
politique telle qu'on l'entend
classiquement et quand on entend parler
quand on entend délivrer un peu quelques
adage comme ça quelques prescriptions
notamment à son à son compagnon qui
ouvre christiane ou l'ouvrier est là
elle parle un peu comme comme un copain
comme comme une drh un peu de
flexibilité et de souplesse de rebond de
choses comme ça toute cette espèce de
novlangue comme ça par lesquels on
essaie de détruire en gros la condition
salariale ou le droit du travail
ben oui donc louisa et est un personnage
gênant pour la gauche on bute sur elle
et moi j'aime bien écrire des livres
là où ça coince là où on bute d'où
peut-être l'importance que vous accordez
dans ce livre aux descriptions des
scènes sexuelles entre les personnages
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de sexualité
dans ce livre c'est là on n'est pas
idéologique
quoique parce qu'on peut se demander
s'il a en fait c'est très intéressant
parce que tout le livre même s'il n'est
pas dictée par une intention et des
logiques vise quand même à décrire sinon
dénoncer un certain rapport de
domination d'une classe sur une autre or
cette domination est les transposer dans
le domaine sexuel et le personnage de
romain presse avec kiel louisa va avoir
une histoire découvre le plaisir
l'excitation qu'il a quand par texto
parce que vous retranscris vais tous les
échanges de textos vous à l'appel m et
là ils découvrent une espèce de
d'érotisme de domination qui
effectivement gras ça ne va pas du tout
avec la dénonciation des doigts voilà
vous résumer bien un des points par
lesquels c'est mon fonctionnement de
travail toujours c'est ce que j'appelle
là où ça coince c'est évidemment là où
les choses son tour circuiter là où tous
les pas simple effectivement pourrait
dire à quelqu'un comme romain presse
petit bourgeois de gauche éduqués par
des parents eux mêmes fonctionnaires
enfin bon c'est un climat que moi je
connais bien personnellement et
évidemment presque féministes avant même
d'y avoir réfléchi on est on est dans
ces milieux-là l'on postule l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes je dors
je connais bien ce milieu moi j'ai
grandi là dedans pour moi ça allait de
soi
oui alors de se découvrir dans les
micros affecte 1 dans les dents des dans
des petites particules comme ça
sensorielle quotidiennement de découvrir
qu'on et érotiser par une maîtresse une
compagne sexuelle qui vous appelle m
alors ça c'est des situations qui me
passionne parce que c'est des
contradictions internes entre les
principes et le corps c'est pas pratique
que le domaine de la sexualité n'est pas
forcément politique moi c'est de dire
que tout est politique m'intéresse assez
peu même s'ils jugent adhère
fondamentalement cette espèce de mode
horde en tout cas de da d'âge ou de
proverbes ou de slogans soixante huitard
et en tant que tel je peux y adhérer
dans ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce que
tout est social ou pas mais tout est
social entendu finement parce qu'en
général les adversaires
faible d'ailleurs de la sociologie ne la
prennent pas au sérieux ils ont jamais
lu dur car ils ont pas vraiment
conséquemment lui bourdieu donc il croit
qu'en gros la sociologie ça consiste à
dire il ya des pauvres les pauvres des
fois ils font des conneries par exemple
ils sont délinquants et moi en tant que
sociologue en fait je vais être sympa je
vais être un peu angélique ou bisounours
où tous ces beaux qu'on avait eu comme
ça submergé notre champ discursif est en
fait mais ce serait d'abord excusé le
pauvre qu'a fait des conneries ce
que c'est pas ça se dit postule en tout
cas constate observe puis postule
l'appartenance sociale l'incorporation
pour chaque individu qu'ils soient
riches pauvres de classe moyenne d'un
certain nombre de diktat sociaux dans un
certain nombre d'institutions dire et
frédéric lordon ce qui s'est institué
louis alors et là ça devient un matériau
très intéressant que vous êtes écrivain
sociologue mais parce que pour eux c'est
le bleu point où ça devient très
intéressant pour un romancier parce que
de voir que justement jusque dans ma
sexualité je peux être conditionné alors
là ça devient assez passionnant et alors
comment est-ce qu'on tient ensemble ce
que vous décrivez donc ce rapport de
domination sexuelle choisi est hautement
érotique dans votre livre et les
réactions qui a lu qu'il y a eu suite à
l'adaptation de votre texte la blessure
la vraie parade et latif kechiche
mektoub my love qui les réactions
étaient assez virulent pour dénoncer le
comportement de ce réalisateur à l'égard
de ses actrices
alors il ya deux choses qu'il faut bien
distinguer il ya le comportement du
réalisateur sur le plateau et là je ne
venais pas le dossier je n'ai pas les
informations mais ça effectivement ça
pourrait être justiciables d'une plainte
ou que ça j'adore ça c'est bon après
autre chose dit elle l'oeuvre d'art est
le film qui nous arrive s'appelle make
to my love
voilà et où effectivement certaines
critiques jeudi certaines chez tous sont
des femmes qui les ont émises ce qui
n'est pas complètement étonnant on ont
critiqué ce qu'on a appelé ce qu'on
appelle désormais de melgueil zain le
regard masculin mais alors là il
faudrait s'entendre sur ce qu'on attend
de l'art est ce que l'art est là pour
être moralement correct pour finalement
être totalement homogène un certain
nombre d'attentes morale légitimes de la
société d'une société donnée à un moment
donné où est ce que l'art au contraire
est là pour ce que j'appelle moi
relancer les dés et met les contrées
remettre les compteurs à zéro
quand j'écris un livre quand je me lance
dans un roman j'essaie d'oublier tout ce
que je pense bien après évidemment que
ça fait retour passe
on n'échappe pas à soi-même mais
j'essaie d'oublier tout ce que je pense
et de n'avoir pour religion que je
dirais la justesse l'intensité
l'intérêt est ce que cette scène est
intéressante entre deux personnages est
ce que c'est juste
voilà c'est ça qui va me guider et non
pas effectivement la conformité de ce
que je vais raconter un certain nombre
oui de principes moraux idéologique
politique
bon alors oui peut-être que abdellatif
kechiche est fasciné par les postérieurs
féminins
bon bah c'est un affect voilà et alors
ils aiment bien les filmer il fait pas
que cela par ailleurs parce que je pense
qu'ils les idées aussi très très fort
pour filmer les femmes tout court les
femmes dans leur grande vitalité dans
leur grand baie le problème est cité
mais pourquoi ce qu'ils aiment les films
et si on sait on comment les réactions
qu'il y à eut hélas encore faire très
attention parce que là on n'est pas du
tout dans un jugement dans un procès
c'est pas le fait de les filmer qui est
dérangeant c'est l'attitude que c'est
l'attitude que ce réalisateur pourrait
avoir envers ces femmes en tant
qu'actrice j'ai commencé par listel
ça c'est des affaires de plateau où je
n'ai pas d'information et j'espère
peut-être qu'un jour il y en a on peut
distinguer complètement l'homme de
l'avre vous pensez c'est une grande
question je sais pas si on peut non non
c'est tout je pas en train de dire
distinguer l'homme de l'oeuvre en
l'occurrence parce que ça c'est nouveau
ça nous prendrait douze mille heures à
peu près non il ya ce qui se passe sur
le plateau plateau et la façon les
méthodes qu'ils utilisent pour diriger
ses actrices
alors si ces méthodes sont considérées
comme sadique et imprimantes moi en tant
que très proche en général du faible
dans une situation sociale donnée je
serai du côté ses actrices
si jamais il est avéré que tel
réalisateur se comporte comme un patron
bouge à 1 comme un harceleur en chef
comme il ya dans beaucoup de lieux de
travail
mais vraiment je pense qu'il faut
préserver non pas l'oeuvre de l'homme
mais l'oeuvre tout court
et le fait que l'art puisse être une
zone d'expérimentation des affects où on
peut libérer un certain nombre des faits
que ça c'est très important
il faut absolument que l'art soit pour
une part par delà bien et mal désolé
d'être un peu
académique et nietzschéen disons
classiquement nietzschéen par cette
expression ça vraiment on aurait presque
envie que vous alliez encore plus loin
dans votre exploration de sa de cette
complexité de la sexualité des liens qui
ne sont pas moreau qui ne sont pas
politiques bas je fais que ça dans pas
mal de mes romans donc je je je vais
aller plus loin je vous rassure je vais
faire d'autres livres c'est le travail
de toute une vie mais il me semble que
pour l'instant je ne pense pas avoir
fait des livres très moralement correct
c'est pas parce que c'est pas ma c'est
pas ma façon de faire et surtout
j'aurais l'impression de trahir ce que
la haute idée que je me fais du champ
esthétique la dimension vous dites vous
assumer d'être un homme de gauche
quand vous dites âmes de gauche comment
est ce qu'il faut le comprendre il ya un
côté libertariens ou est ce que c'est
une certaine partie de la gauche comment
est-ce que vous identifier alors
libertariens sûrement pas même si c'est
un mouvement qui m'intéresse beaucoup
les libertariens américain m'intéresse
beaucoup comme le libéralisme tel que
foucault l'a étudiée et tels que pierre
rosanvallon qu'il va nous rejoindre tout
à leur rappelle que fukuda étudier
toutes ces choses m'intéressent beaucoup
mais non pas libertariens libertaire
éventuellement libertaire éventuellement
mais où le moungo ça veut dire
libertaire je crois que c'est devoir en
toute situation où l oppression où l
empêchement ou et la coercition et
d'essayer de se donner les moyens de
s'émanciper de ses coercition la voilà
c'est ça c'est ça l'impulsion libertaire
bon je pense qu'on est très largement
aliéné par notre travail par exemple on
est très aliéné par notre emploi du
temps nous sommes des multi aliénés
alors je pense qu'il peut on peut
recenser les aliénations et pour toute
aliénation se demander mais comment
pourrait-il se faire que ce corps qui
présentement est entravée pourrait ce
désastre avait c'est ça qu'on appelle
dans l'émancipation bien sûr bien sûr
que ça ne parle que ça ne passe que par
le corps ça passe par l'individu je
pense que fondamentalement et de gauche
est individualiste au sens littéral du
terme pas au sens où je pense qu'à ma
gueule ce sera aussi des rations morale
qui m'intéresse pas mais individus
valley sert toujours de repartir de
l'individu dans quelle mesure l'individu
dans son épanouissement et dans son
émancipation est empêchée empêché par
des structures et dans quelle mesure
pourrons nous relancer ces structures de
sorte que cet individu puisse s'en
libérer l'horizon d'ailleurs pierre
rosanvallon le
rappel aussi dans son très beau livre il
rappelle que la première impulsion de
marx l'horizon ultime du marxisme c'est
l'individu c'est l'émancipation de
l'individu c'est son épanouissement
c'est le la reconstitution de la
plénitude individuelles contre les
structures qui a déjà eu lieu une
reconstitution via une époque dans
l'humanité où l'homme était absolument
en pleine possession de tous ses moyens
et ce qu'elle passe toujours eue c'est
cette oppression c'est bien sûr le jeu
reconnaît là votre rigueur philosophique
je pense qu'on peut je pense que c'est
un écart de langage que je viens d'avoir
parce qu'effectivement en fait il
faudrait postuler comme rousseau
d'ailleurs postule un état de nature
sans y croire lui même donc on
postulerait un premier individu qui
serait n'ont empêché qui serait prêt
social s'est très largement une fiction
intellectuel mais c'est intéressant elle
et elle est productive cette fiction
intellectuelle pour voir jusqu'à quel
point la structure sociale peut nous
aliéner nous et ce que l'on souhaite
parce que le finalement la question se
pose de savoir si l'idéal ce qui peut
conduire au soulèvement n'est pas trop
idéal au point que ça devienne
complètement irréel et qu'au fond nous
vouloir renoncer à toute forme
d'oppression de déterminisme est
complètement illusoire
je crois que cette affaire d'idéal mois
alors vraiment par exemple c'est un lomo
idéal est un mot qui n'appartient pas à
mon vocabulaire et je peux vous dire
qu'un marxiste conséquence je suis pas
sûr dans les trains mais j'essaie de me
tenir un peu dans cette grande grande
tradition intellectuelle que celle du
marxisme grande tradition intellectuelle
déjà un beaucoup de textes extrêmement
puissant c'est ça c'est ça qui pour moi
défendra toujours le marxisme en
dernière instance
bon l'idéal est un mot fallait voir si
c'est construit contre l' idéalisme
philosophiquement donc j'ai pas d'idée
au en revanche prenons les situations
une par une et vous savez très bien que
être de gauche ce n'est pas envisagé une
espèce de stade de perfection d'absolu
utopique qui serait le plein
épanouissement de l'individu mais non il
faut pragmatiquement regarde regardez où
on en est et essayer de tendre vers des
choses essayer de tendre vers l'est mais
ça c'est quelque chose qui est partagé
par toute la société à droite comme à
gauche et est même encore ailleurs non
non se défaire des structures qui nous
empêche de faire ce qu'on voudrait faire
trop de gens pensent que je vois
énormément de forces sociales s'activer
dans le champ
d'une société donnée pour empêcher
d'autres gens de s'émanciper
il ya des gens qui encore une fois sont
là pour préserver leurs intérêts et qui
sont prêts à le faire à tous à tous les
prix y compris au prix de l'aliénation
d'une grande partie de l'humanité donc
sans doute que ces gens seraient
absolument libéraux au sens premier du
terme est presque presque noble du terme
dans un dîner en ville en disant qu'il
son tour que des gens soient lire ils
sont peut être atteints sauf qu'en fait
ils activent eux-mêmes des machines ou
participent à une structure qui aliène à
moitié de l'humanité voire les trois cas
mais c'est peut-être que marx n'avait
pas vu parce qu'il avait prévu que le
capitalisme allait entraîner une
paupérisation de la société horse a
entraîné un enrichissement d'une grande
partie de la population oui c'est vrai
mais c'est pas des débats que j'ai envie
de mener ici je voulais parce que le
contre-argument libéral de dire que ça
enrichit la la population doit d'abord
été discutable
faudrait voir les chiffres donc voilà
j'ai pas envie de rentrer là dedans
parce que d'abord c'est techniquement un
débat que je ne peux pas assumer en plus
il m'intéresse pas beaucoup
intellectuellement l'important est de
voir comment nous vivons là maintenant
dans une situation donnée
moi je voulais dans en guerre me réduire
au social français j'ai essayé de
réduire un peu le champ c'est toujours
intéressant pour que le laboratoire soit
d'autant plus efficace en quelque sorte
enfin en tout cas pertinents
bon ben je constate que quand même les
classes populaires en france par exemple
ou dans d'autres pays probablement bon
il faut voir quelle est leur quotidien
quelle est la vie quotidienne
l'intérieur quelle est la vie
quotidienne de quelqu'un qui comme
louisa travail dans un entrepôt amazon
amazon c'est pas du vieux capitaliste du
19e
c'est amazon c'est l'avant garde du
capitalisme c mais ces mêmes jeux on
peut même dire que je pense qu'on peut
voir arriver une espèce d'amazon isation
du monde du travail probablement dans
les années à venir comme il ya une
numérisation du monde du travail une
destruction du salariat destruction un
certain nombre de protections
comment vivent les prolétaires comment
vivre les classes inférieures dans une
société donnée
cette vie n'est pas vivable on le voit
très bien la lecture de ce livre et même
une forme de
de fatalité très sombre qui s'abat sur
les personnages sont tous révélés
évidemment le geste de l'écriture
lui-même ne conduit pas à un appel au
soulèvement
ça c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire non
mais c'est pas moi j'ai pas la fonction
que je signe à 1 livre 1 première
fonction d'un livre est un bon vivre et
ça c'est à la discrétion du lecteur donc
chacun jugera
chacun a jugé chacun jugera et est ce
que je vous disais est ce qu'il est
juste et ce que en tout cas par où il se
propose d'être juste et ce qu'il a
réalisé son ambition c'est aussi au
lecteur d'en juger d'une certaine
manière on s'en remet totalement à lui
mais par contre maintenant je moi je
n'écris pas des livres pour ne pas
désespérer billancourt ou pour soulever
les troupes jeu quand on fait de la
littérature ont fait de la littérature
ya un temps pour tout et puis des fois
je vais manifester là je sais pourquoi
je me dis à la question de savoir
comment est-ce que l'intellectuel où
l'écrivain peut par ailleurs combiner de
son activité avec un engagement
politique je propose qu'on continue sa
discussion avec pierre rosanvallon qui
va nous rejoindre sur ce plateau et qui
va nous aider à décrire l'état de la
gauche aujourd'hui entre autres
[Musique]
bonjour pierre rosanvallon
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur le
plateau de livres et vous votre livre
s'appelle notre histoire intellectuelle
et politique de 1968 à 2018 les paru aux
éditions du seuil
est ce que c'est le livre d'un homme de
gauche oui c'est le livre d'un homme de
gauche au sens le plus générique de
signifierait gauche la gauche ceux ci
fit d'abord le refus de la fatalité et
or aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation il ya un sentiment
d'impuissance et un sentiment
d'endormissement un sentiment de
désarroi et je crois que là la première
dimension morale de la gauche et cela
c'est vouloir surmonter le désarroi
purger l'impuissance purger le
désenchantement pour réarmer en
permanence le présent ça je dirais c'est
l'attitude psychologique de la gauche et
puis il ya aussi le programme bien sûr
et le programme de la gauche c'est tout
simplement celui de vouloir
l'émancipation des individus dans ses
différentes dimensions faire sortir les
hommes et les femmes de l'état de
minorités comme on la fameuse demande y
est je pense que cela se décline et cela
a une pertinence une pertinence
historique qui a été en quelque sorte
qui a subi un moment de cristallisation
au moment des grandes révolutions
modernes les grandes révolutions
modernes justement ont voulu briser la
fatalité de la nature briser la fatalité
d'une certaine domination dans
l'absolutisme politique brise est aussi
là la fatalité de rapports hiérarchiques
entre les individus
mais ce programme il n'a cessé d'avoir
une actualité il a eu ses moments de
progression il a eu ses moments
d'attentes
il a ses moments de régression et
sûrement qu'actuellement nous sommes
dans un moment où de régression au sens
très large du terme pourrait-on dire
mais je crois que si on confond la
gauche avec les institutions les parties
à ce moment là le mont gauche en quelque
sorte il est rapetissée et si on veut
l'agrandir eh bien il faut lui donner
cette dimension historique
vous savez au 19e siècle qui avait
beaucoup de livres on parlait pas de la
gauche à l'époque on commence à parler
du socialisme le terme et de 1830 et
quand on faisait
voire du socialisme à l'époque les
grandes usines elles commençaient tout
juste le mouvement ouvrier
il était encore dans l'enfantement mais
ont commencé les histoires du socialisme
immanquablement par un char pin sur
spartacus voyez pour montrer qu'ils
avaient une histoire très longue la voix
de récits sans doute établi une rupture
avec ses ouvrages sur le socialisme et
sur un certain récit de la gauche il
s'appelle notre histoire intellectuelle
et politique
et vous dites je c'est aussi un livre
qui mêle des éléments autobiographiques
allez vous êtes vous dans ce livre eh
bien je suis à la fois le je et le nous
je puis dire je suis le nous parce que
ça fait beaucoup
oui c'est très nombreux oui mais ce nom
se nourrit les multitudes parce que
c'est tout de même les enfants de 68 et
en même l'histoire de la deuxième gauche
et plus largement l'histoire de la
gauche c'est l'histoire de mouvements
sociaux
c'est l'histoire du syndicalisme dans
laquelle j'ai été impliqué pendant
presque huit ans et puis cette histoire
ses jeux pourquoi parceque il m'a semblé
moi j'ai écrit beaucoup de livres
d'histoire j'écris des livres plutôt de
théorie politique ou de philosophie
politique
il m'a semblé qu'un moment si l'on
voulait donner une vraie consistance aux
expériences
il fallait aussi leur donner un côté
sensible les problèmes de la gauche
c'est pas simplement les idées les
problèmes de la gauche ce sont aussi des
émotions se sont déjà fait alors
pourquoi pas mon histoire intellectuelle
et politique en france on a beaucoup du
mal à dire jeu dans les essais ce que
les anglo saxons ne se pose pas du tout
comme problème ces masters donc oui bien
sûr c'est en partie mon histoire mais
c'est aussi une histoire plus large donc
je mêle le je et le nous c'est pas par
timidité et puis ça n'est pas tout mon
histoire justement c'est mon histoire en
tant qu elle intéresse cette histoire
plus générale de la gauche depuis 50 ans
mais je ne parle pas de ma jeunesse je
ne parle pas de mes parents je ne parle
pas de de tout un ensemble de choses qui
seraient redevables
normalement ce qu'on qualifie de mémoire
ça n'était pas le sujet françois
bégaudeau la borne que vous avez choisi
pierre rosanvallon c'est 1968 2018 est
ce que c'est votre histoire aussi de la
gauche
bah écoutes je suis né en 71 donc ça
correspond assez bien pour être lus sur
ma vie mais
et là j'ai été déçu en étant un peu
voilà c'est la seule faiblesse du livre
moi c'est vrai que je viens j'ai eu je
racontais aussi pour ce livre que je
mentionnais plus avec sa pelle de ça je
me dis politique moi j'ai grandi dans
les années 80 je me suis formé
intellectuellement aux années 80 j'étais
ado et puis après étudiants et j'étais à
contretemps puisque effectivement et
pierre le raconte très très bien à quel
point les années 80 ont été
traumatisante intellectuellement pour la
gauche quoi ça a été un des grands
moments de reflux de reflux de réaction
de régression de dabo l'ismans du champ
intellectuel ya des phrases de guéthary
que je trouve assez génial là dessus et
qui en ont déprimé par divers ils disent
les uns les divers la saison - a pas de
pas de diversité
donc moi je suis dans les années 80 je
découvre finalement ce c'est mina cette
constellation intellectuelle absolument
génial des années 60 70 50 60 70
c'est à dire quand même moi qui ai quand
même l'âge d'or de la philosophie
française ou de la pensée française
bourdieu derrida elle pue c'est à ce
qu'un certain point rancière qui
débarque dans les années 70 évidemment
deleuze évidemment guéthary et tout un
tas d'autres quoi les jeudis prouve sa
précisément au moment où l'ensemble de
la société voudrait un petit peu oublié
révoqué ce grand moment de la pensée
française dont fait partie d'ailleurs
pierre rosanvallon bien il fait partie
aussi la deuxième gauche la grande
aventure de cfdt
la grande aventure du ps eu de
l'autogestion tout ça je le découvre
dans les années 80 mais au moment où
tout me dit autour de moi que tout ça
est fini
donc j'ai toujours moi grandi dans un
certain contretemps mais je dois dire
que depuis ses revenus et des années 90
et dans les années 2000 et là j'ai vu
deux nouveaux fleury réapparaître tout
une comme ça tout une vitalité
intellectuelle et réflexive de la gauche
radicale celle qu'il m'intéresse le plus
la bouche de gauche comme disait
bourdieu
je trouve qu'on vit une époque qui est
particulièrement riche une grande grande
ébullition intellectuelle du côté de la
gauche
alors comment définir la gauche
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on pourrait dire
et je le dis de manière un peu
caricaturale pour vous puissiez affiner
les choses car locaux conflit originale
qui a structuré la gauche on nous par
exemple tout à l'heure françois
bégaudeau de lutte des classes entre la
bourgeoisie ou contrôler prolétariat le
prolétariat contre la bourgeoisie s'est
substitué un nouveau conflit qui serait
par exemple
l'universalisme contre le
communautarisme non je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse se présenter les choses
comme cela il faut il faut voir que dans
cette histoire générale de
l'émancipation qui résume l'histoire de
la gauche et différentes dimensions
n'est que ça n'a pas été par tous les
abandons une dimension très importante
sinon une dimension essentielle était
celle de la conquête des droits et 7
cette dimension de la conquête des
droits qui a été le grand combat
historique
il a été remis vivier en 1968 avec
l'idée d'un monde moi hiérarchique d'un
monde plus autonome et des mots nouveaux
qui sont apparus voulait dire aussi un
pas en avant dans cette émancipation des
individus par les droits et ceux là oui
ça tracer une route qui continue
aujourd'hui sa tracé une route qui est
grande différence entre la gauche de 68
et celle d'aujourd'hui sur certains
points mais sur sur le point des droits
nous de toutes les grandes idées de 68
de donner des droits aux femmes si
quelque chose
le combat continue aujourd'hui et il a
été permanent le fait de reconnaître
différemment l'enfant c'est quelque
chose qui a commencé qui continue
aujourd'hui
le fait de vouloir un rapport les
individus ne soit pas simplement soumis
aux institutions mais des droits face à
elle c'est quelque chose qui continue
alors ou 7 oui il ya là il ya une
histoire de la gauche qui est une
histoire qui elle n'a pas fléchi mais
vous êtes chez qui le parti socialiste
n'existe plus trop à la gauche de la
gauche vous disais la gauche radicale
qui est le représentant de cette couche
pratique moi je parle moins leur
représentation politique et le jeu
partidaire m'intéresse pas donc moi
l'histoire du parti socialiste pardon
mais je la gauche parce que c'est ce que
je parlais nathan faire un champ
intellectuel je pourrais vous lister je
vais pas le faire ce serait du même nom
mais les intellectuels non
le monopole de la gauche non plus non
mais j'entends bien évidemment pas mais
mais je trouve qu'actuellement moi qui
suis très client effrayant de penser à
gauche
je trouve qu'il ya une vraie est ce que
j'appelle mes une ébullition
je pense que quoi qu'on en pense par
ailleurs quoi qu'on en pense par
ailleurs et quelques objections qu'on
pourrait avoir à lui opposer je pense
que frédéric lordon est un grand penseur
est un penseur d'une grande puissance
eh bien il nous il nous est contemporain
et je pourrais vous citer bernard friot
d'un intellectuel tout à fait passion
voici tes pierre bien sûr mais je
précisais plein d'autres gens je pense
qu'il y a si vous voulez de la galerie
par exemple mais par exemple avec on
pourrait discuter des heures sur
geoffroy de lagasnerie mais oui je crois
qu'il a par exemple écrit un
chef-d'oeuvre qui s'appelle jugé oui
c'est un grand livre je pense que la
gauche dans sa partie intellectuelle en
tout cas produit des grands livres
depuis dix quinze vingt ans il faut le
savoir quand même alors c'est souvent un
continent relativement inaperçu par le
mainstream ou par le champ médiatique je
dirais mais c'est ils n'ont hinault
raisonnement qu'il existe des raisons je
dirais deux choses je pense
effectivement que la gauche se définit
aussi par donné par forget des concepts
qui se meuvent armée la société un des
buts historique de la gauche a tout de
même été cela c'est de permettre aux
citoyens de comprendre là où il en est
de trouver les mots qui correspondent à
ce qu'il vit est de ce point de vue là
il ya un rapport entre la production des
concepts je dirais et la littérature
parce que la littérature le langage il
aussi pour but d'aider à comprendre
autrement la réalité de la dire
autrement
donc ça c'est un travail anses et quels
sont les concepts de la gauche par
exemple par exemple le concept de lago
le concept de la gauche celui des droits
celui de l'autonomie c'est un concept
central et on voit bien aujourd'hui que
si on veut parler par exemple de la pma
bassiste année c'est un point
d'application des droits mais ce
problème de l'autonomie ce problème du
détachement de nature il est au coeur de
ceux de ce problème a contredit par la
droite aujourd'hui personne en appel à
moins d'autonomie sans une fois dix ans
qui a des définitions concurrente pour
le moins il ya des définitions
concurrents de l'autonomie est
aujourd'hui en tout cas il ya bien des
personnes qu'il pensent que la grande la
grande haie
heures de l'humanité a été de vouloir se
mettre au dessus de la nature alors que
l'idée de l'émancipation c'est tout de
même les hommes et les femmes prennent
le pas sur la nature ils sortent de la
fatalité et aujourd'hui il ya bien des
voix qui nous enjoignent au contraire de
faire retour à cette fatalité et de
l'accepter donc cette dimension des
idées elle est présente on pourra dire
tout à l'heure qui à bien des domaines
dans lequel ces balbutiant mais il ya
aussi c'est pas simplement des idées
c'est aussi beaucoup d'associations
beaucoup de militantisme du quotidien si
vous réduisez la gauche au moment
électoral
une fois tous les quatre ou cinq ans
effectivement vous allez dire c'est peu
de chose les parties s'étiole il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes qui
s'abstiennent
mais si vous appelez la gauche ce qui
sur le terrain sont dans des
associations qui font de l'entr'aide qui
produisent du commun qui sont
véritablement je dirais ceux qui font
tenir debout la société si on voit que
la société qu'envoûtant le livre
françois bégaudeau peut être décrite
comme une société en crise une société
en guerre comment cette société peut
encore tenir si bien à côté de tout cela
il ya tout de même des militants du
quotidien
il ya tout de même des milliers
l'association moi je passe une partie de
ma vie dans un petit bourg de la drôme
mais dans ce petit bourg de la drôme
d'après d'une centaine d'associations
mais est-ce que les risques à ne pas
tomber dans une forme de manichéisme où
la gauche seraient tous ceux qui
essayent de faire tenir ensemble la
société quand la droite où les autres
d'ailleurs parce qu'on n'a pas encore
parlé de maquereaux et dans marche sont
ceux qui au contraire ne pensent qu'à
eux et nuisent au vivre ensemble pour
reprendre ça n'est pas le manichéisme
mais disons qui a tout de même
historiquement un investissement dans le
monde associatif qui a été plus fort à
gauche c'est un c'est un fait mais
derrière derrière cet investissement
associatif il faut aussi donner à cet
investissement associatif
ddd ressort intellectuelle il faut lui
donner non simplement de les objectifs
du monde là si on dit simplement qu'il
faut plus dire mme plus d'émancipation
que liberté et tout le monde est pour
mais aujourd'hui regardez la critique du
capitalisme après tout la grande
histoire de la gauche s'était aussi
qu'on est passé d'un prêt capitalisme
tout les toutes les idées d'émancipation
ils ont été formulées dans les
révolutions anglaise américaine
française un moment où c'était encore le
vieux monde de l'économie domestique
oui et aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on
arrive dans un nouveau capitalisme ont
parlé d' amazon de cette un exemple
parmi d'autres mais ce nouveau
capitalisme dans lequel ça n'est plus
tellement les moyens de production mais
la propriété intellectuelle qui devient
véritablement le le ressort essentiel à
la fois de la production de valeur et de
la domination
ce nouveau capitalisme il commence
seulement à être analysées et à être
théorisé donc je pense que nous
effectivement je suis d'accord pour dire
que nous nous voyons que nous commençons
à sortir de l'état de léthargie mais il
ya bien des domaines dans lesquels même
concernant la la définition de la
démocratie
oui mais précisément parce que la
définition de la démocratie vous dit
l'un et l'autre que la gauche n'est pas
forcément la représentation le parti
politique mais le problème c'est que
s'ils ont désinvesti cette dimension là
déjà il ya un problème même
politiquement en france parce que le
parti qui aujourd'hui gouvernement n'a
plus d'opposition ce qui découle dans
une forme de déliquescence interne et
seconde manche deuxièmement le problème
est aussi comme si à plus de
représentation politique et bien est-ce
qu'au moment de voter les électeurs dits
de gauche ne vont pas aller voter dans
ce pour des candidats qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui de populiste ce qui flatte
l'ego du peuple plutôt que de proposer
un projet politique viable france avait
d'abord moi le mot de populisme
non merci e pierre commence tard d'un
jeu chantal move parle d'un peu pour un
tourisme dans ce sens il a donc sur la
notion de populisme de gauche on
pourrait on pourrait faire une émission
aussi et sur chantal mouche et sur la
clau avec lequel elle a elle a mis au
point ce concept mais vous voyez bien
que ce n'est pas cet usage là qui va
être fait pendant les quatre mois qui
viennent avant les élections européennes
du mot puis ce sera un usage strictement
stigmatisant un petit peu comme vous
venez de le dire d'ailleurs dans une
ville d'exception de on flatte
démagogiquement les mauvais instincts du
peuple là dessus je vous renvoie au
développement de rancière sur ces
questions là parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce truc de vouloir attribuer
au peuple des modèles instinct comme si
le peuple avait le monopole du racisme
non celle inverse
mais non c'est ce qu'ils présentent
comme les représentants du peuple qui
parient sur la présence de ces mauvaises
c'est un moule est d'accord mais je ne
me définis populis patientant dans la
stigmatisation tokyo 10 je pense que
quand même et là je le ramènerait je
crois que je développe un peu cette idée
dans un essai à paraître
je crois que dans l'incrimination peu
plus 10 il ya quand même une vieille
peur bourgeoise des classes populaires
et je pense qu'en fait c'est un un
nouvel avatar voulait une espèce de
nouvelles voulait qui sera je pense que
s'il est possible d'un point de vue de
rigueur intellectuelle ce monde veut
rien dire vraiment je le maintiens et
qu'on pourrait avoir ce débat avec
pierre parce qu'il va de toute façon il
annonce des travaux sur la question avec
grande attention
mais en l'état je trouve que il n'y n'a
pas de contenu sérieux en revanche il a
un usage et je vois les gens qui en font
usage actuellement qui en font
d'ailleurs je veux dire immodérément usa
chez le mot de la décennie populiste et
est vraiment on va il va nous casser les
oreilles jusqu'aux élections européennes
et puis peut-être après avant d'autres
échéances
alors je vois bien quel usage il a il a
un usage de vieilles incrimination des
classes populaires et à ce titre là je
pense que son usage même vous marque
vous vous assigne à 1 quand vous vous
identifie pour moi politiquement pas
vous personnellement
celui qui en fait usage je crois que
devrait d'accord que ceux qui parlent le
populisme c'est toujours les dirigeants
aient jamais le peuple lui même c'est à
dire vous faites comme si en fait c'est
le peuple c'est ce qu'ils veulent je
disais je j'aime le populiste la mecque
toujours à ce tribun de la part de l'
usage confond actuellement et c'est pas
les gens du peuple qui font usage du
populaire justice et des journalistes
c'est des éditorialistes etc quant à
savoir si ce n'est de nous attribuer je
sais pas ce que dirait pierre mais en
tout cas moi je me sens pas responsable
de l'état de la démocratie
représentative hôtel qu'elle se joue
depuis deux cents ans ou alors plus
sûrement depuis 150 ans hambourg depuis
la 3ème république dise trouve que je
vote pas mais c'est anecdotique en
l'occurrence mais je devrai moi je n'ai
je pas dans ces termes là que je
réfléchissais au sens où à la gauche
n'aurait plus de représentants de partis
comme ça qui les représenterait donc du
coup ça ouvrirait la voie par exemple
aux populistes ou à eau et autres
mauvais instincts sais que c'est pas mon
problème - en l'occurrence je pense même
que je vais vous dire un truc plus clair
encore si fiers de la gauche ferait sans
doute bien
un de ne pas se présenter aux prochaines
sélections présentes présidentielle de
ne pas du tout avoir un parti qui
sembleraient l'incarner je pense que ce
serait un très grand moment démocratique
donc on ne voudrait côté présidentiel
prochain on pense à des connaisseurs je
me présente c'est pour cela des nations
les populismes bon qu'il y ait un mot en
paix qui soit de toute façon il faut
voir que son usage a beaucoup changé
parce que le mot populisme n'était pas
du tout utilisé ya quinzaine d'années on
parlait de la nouvelle extrême droite
par exemple et qui est une réalité
partout présente en europe
peu à peu si on employait le terme
populiste c'est aussi qu'on a vu que ça
n'était pas simplement l'extrême droite
d'hier mais que s'ajoutaient des
facteurs nouveaux
donc on achète essayé d'employer ce mot
qui mêlait une tentative de décrire une
réalité politique émergente c'est-à-dire
l'extension d'une extrême droite mais
qui aller beaucoup plus loin
même dans ses références que l'extrême
droite classique et puis le mail et avec
la peur ancien du peuple disons et les
deux les deux se mêlant ce qui rend
maintenant la discussion peut être un
peu différente c'est qu'il ya toute une
revendication d'un certain nombre de
partis de gauche qui accepte le mot
populisme même jean luc mélenchon
accepte maintenant le mot populisme
qu'il refusait avant mais ne discutons
pas vraiment du terme lui-même ce qui
est important c'est qu'il ya des
réalités politiques nouvelle extrêmement
puissante que l'on voit dans tous les
pays européens convoi en amérique du sud
qu'on voit dans les pays de l'est ce
coup qu'on voit aux philippines convoi
en inde
alors laissons de côté la dénomination
de savoir si le mot populisme est
adéquat c'est secondaire
mais qu'il ya effectivement une nouvelle
vision de la démocratie qu'il ya
effectivement une nouvelle vision de la
justice sociale fondé une vision de
l'égalité qui n'ont pu fonder sur le
travail d'une société d'égaux mais qui
est fondée sur un principe d'exclusion
une démocratie qui est fondée sur
l'identification à un leader un roger
des corps intermédiaires il ya bien tout
un ensemble de phénomènes politiques et
sociaux nous voulons que l'on voit
apparaître indépendamment là encore que
leur qualification et c'est eux qui ont
le vent en poupe aujourd'hui est
derrière
et derrière cette montée en puissance eh
bien il ya beaucoup de data qu'à la
liberté qui se mettre dehors
il ya beaucoup d'illusions sur l'égalité
mais n'est ce pas une bonne raison pour
que la gauche réinvestissent ne
réinvestissent part dans la
représentation et jacques maurice barrès
disait en 1893 grande période des
élections législatives il disait je suis
devenu national protectionnistes pour
être fidèle au socialisme de mayonnaise
et bien aujourd'hui il ya un petit peu
ça qui se passe donc le donc le problème
n'est pas simplement de lever les bras
au ciel en disant manne de la gauche
descendez gentiment vers nous non si la
gauche est dans la situation électorale
qui est la sienne c'est parce que la
gauche est dans le silence
intellectuelle dans laquelle elle est
mais vous semblez dire linverse non moi
je suis pas d'accord oui ça je pense pas
qu'il y avait deux choses à dire et je
pense qu'il ya vraiment pas une
comment dire une vacance intellectuelle
de la gauche vraiment je pense qu'il ya
une vraie dynamique une vraie vitalité
intellectuelle d'une certaine gauche en
tout cas celle qui m'intéresse le plus
et à laquelle je tu as aussi d'ailleurs
et et deuxièmement c'est une petite
objections que j'entends une objection
une discussion que kim et qui m'est
venue en lisant ce très beau livre de
pierre rosanvallon
je pense que c'est la place que vous
attribuez aux idées moi je suis pas sûr
évidemment en tant qu'intellectuel nous
sommes en attente 10 des voix la nounou
3 ici puis d'autres gens ceux qui nous
regardent probablement on est en attente
d'idées et parfois dans la mesure où on
a un goût pour les idées on glisse vers
les dévers la conviction que c'est des
idées qui nous manque et compris
politiquement il faudrait d'abord avoir
des idées claires pour pouvoir refonder
un certain nombre de lutte ou de
mouvements d'émancipation
moi je crois pas du tout plage là dessus
je crois que je suis très matérialiste
mas de la maladière
mais je crois pas contrairement à pierre
je crois je ne signe pas précisément aux
ide
et le fait d'être motrice dans les
luttes d'émancipation évidemment qu'il y
en a toujours des idées elles sont elles
sont là ça parle ça discours ça élabore
il ya des agencements intellectuels qui
sont importants mais je ne crois pas
qu'il soit moteur moi ce dont manque je
crois profondément il a peut-être que je
suis sottement matérialiste au manque de
force à ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on n'a pas le peuple
on n'a pas les classes populaires c'est
ça le vrai sujet nous les intellectuels
la gauche la gauche la gauche la gauche
d'émancipation il nous manque les
classes populaires c'est bien ça qui
nous manque c'est pas des idées parce
que encore une fois moi au contraire me
fera beaucoup si vous voulez je vois à
quel point la vitalité intellectuelle
dont je parle qui est vraiment
exceptionnel la faille avant d'une
constellation comme ça vraiment il ya de
quoi lire quoi il ya de quoi écouter il
ya de quoi manger il ya de quoi
s'abreuver en permanence de concepts
voilà est en même temps président ça ne
produit pas de force un problème en part
électorale sociale ne sais quel la même
façon je suis d'accord pour dire que les
idées compte en tant qu elles sont des
forces matérielles mais les idées
prenons moi je ne discours pas en
général je prends deux exemples il ya un
sentiment aujourd'hui dans toute une
partie de la société de ne pas être
représenté de ne pas être écoutés de ne
pas compter pour quelque chose et qui
prend en charge cela est bien
effectivement tous ces partis qu'on
appelle p1 disent oui nous nous allons
vous représentez nous nous parlons des
invisibles
nous nous sommes pour que chacun compte
pour quelque chose est en fait qu il le
met derrière là vous parlez du populisme
du populisme je n'ai pas prononcés ils
ne mettent derrière rien de précis alors
que je pense qu'on peut définir
justement un type de démocratie qui ne
soit pas simplement une démocratie qui
vise à l'amélioration de la démocratie
représentative mais une démocratie si la
matière est la force qui nous montrent
pourquoi écrire des livres alors
vraiment parce que si c'est les psy pas
les idées qui nous manquent à quoi à
quoi ça sert d'écrire des romans et des
livres à écrire des livres sert d'abord
à écrire des livres gelé on peut quand
même avoir un goût pour la littérature
on peut trouver que c'est très important
que la littérature continue et donc en
est soi même un peu le soldat peut
sentir frustré de voir que
le combat idéologique qui est le nôtre
n'est pas suivi par les personnes qui
sont censées être associée à ce
mouvement et que écrire les livres ne va
pas les aider à s'associer
mais si vous voulez si vous prenez
affectivement les choses quelles sont
les affects au travail qu'en tant
d'intellectuels écrit un livre c'est que
c'est de l'autoérotisme c'est que on
écrit des livres pas pour servir la
cause
il peut il peut se trouver
qu'accessoirement et incidemment et
presque par surcroît comme on disait en
théologie un livre puisse aider la cause
la servir en tout cas et participer de
la lutte ou du mouvement mais c'est pas
ça qui traversent le corps d'un
intellectuel quand il se met au boulot
pendant une heure on écrire ça érotique
vous dit c'est parce que m'écrire il
aime faire des phrases il aime agences
et des idées peut-être aussi qui pour sa
100e cape pire c'est mon cas aussi quand
j'écris j'écris d'abord à mon propre
usage
je pense que c'est le cas de pierre
husson j'écris à mon propre usage c'est
sûr c'est pour me rendais idées plus
claires mais voilà que j'ai écrit ce
livre là mais je ne suis pas aussi
pessimiste franc rapidement d'eau sur
les idées parce que je vois par exemple
j'ai beaucoup développé l'idée pas
simplement d'une démocratie d'élections
mais d'une démocratie de surveillance
d'une démocratie de contrôle où on ne
s'occupe pas simplement de la voix du
peuple mais de l'oeil du peuple et bien
quand je vois que naissent des
institutions comme transparancy
international qu'on ait des institutions
comme anticorps quand les citoyens
s'intéressent dans la presse justement
avoir l'oeil et bien je dis que de ce
point de vue là on voit que ses idées
cette vision de la démocratie de
surveillance de contrôle
eh bien elle produit des effets et
quelle c est les réapproprier par les
citoyens et on rapprochera la gauche des
territoires de la société qu'elle a
perdue qu'elle a perdu on le voit bien
tous les jours quand justement elle aura
une politique qui propose de redonner de
la visibilité du pouvoir de
l'intelligence aux gens et de ne pas les
condamner à croire aux solutions
miracles et de ne pas simplement les
condamnés à penser que les fantasmes
sont ceux qui va les sauver
bon vous aimez écrire des livres pour
vous mais moi j'aime bien donner envie
de les lire aux autres ça tombe bien je
vous ai demandé d'en amener trois chacun
trois livres qui ont compté pour vous
qui sont vos livres de chevet vous
aider à vous former intellectuellement
ou chivu divertissent tout simplement
françois bégaudeau quels sont les livres
que vous avez apporté alors d'abord
nathalie quintane et que sorti cette
année on atterrit quintin que je tiens
pour une des auteures un des auteurs
selon les usages les plus importants en
france depuis 15 ans alors une vraie
littéraire l1 elle croit à la
littérature mais elle se situe aussi
dans une tradition qu'on pourrait
appeler une certaine modernité
esthétique d'ailleurs qui pensent que le
geste littéraire et le geste politique
sont non pas conforme est analogue
c'était il ya une analogie qui se crée
c'est quoi
l'émancipation politique c'est de
vouloir changer les formes de vie
changer les formes de vie à des formes
qui nous sont imposées et on essaie de
dérégler ses formes pour essayer
d'inventer de nouvelles formes de vie
quotidienne de vie tout court en
littérature il n'ya de littérature digne
de ce nom que si on réinvente un peu les
formes littéraires donné les formes
standard et voilà ma télé cappone se
situe au point de jonction entre ces
deux hypothèses formel c'est noté
le deuxième alors gombrowicz cosmos
parce que bon c'est un livre que j'ai lu
je crois 13 fois fin bronze le picon
retiens de mes écrivains préférés mais
j'ai pris cosmos parce que j'entendais
récemment lordon j'en reparle qui
aiderait delà de la condition anarchique
du nom de son dernier livre que je
recommande mais il disait que finalement
comme ça au détour d'une interview c'est
que c'est la littérature qui mieux qu
aucune autre a pu prélever ce qui est
notre condition qu'ils appellent
anarchique sur la condition anarchique
c'est que le monde n'a pas de fondement
le monde n'a pas de sens
le monde est branlant comme disait à peu
près montagne c'est la littérature qui
recueille ça alors lui si tu es faut que
j'avais de super skis en quoi il a tout
à fait raison je crois que le grand
livre quand même de l'absence de
fondement que compromis de chapelets
d'immaturité une certaine manière
l'immaturité du monde c'est cosmos alors
ça crée une sorte de bureau l'ess s'est
par ailleurs très drôle puisque on sait
bien que tous les grands livres sont
drôles c'est connu on est même si ce
même si petit par la taille et le
dernier alors bon tu aurais j'aurais pu
prendre tous les niches comme ça j'ai
pris est chez homo parce que parce que
c'est son dernier avant la crise avant
la phase i avant le cheval de turin tout
ça et c'est son livre le plus subjectif
c'est avec nietzsche en fait est un
philosophe pour les littéraires en fait
parce que il a subjective et la
philosophie toute philosophie 10 de
seconde pour lui doit partir de
l'individu doit partir de la
subjectivité et là c'est le
vous il se ressentent le plus sur sa
subjectivité puisqu'il dit même comment
y mange comment il boit comment il
marche
qu'est ce qui se passe dans son corps
puisque nietzsche est convaincu que les
idées viennent du corps sont des espèces
de projection des affects idée est
affective donc de ce point de vue là moi
je moi j'aimerais que tous les penseurs
fassler ecce homo est par exemple
j'aimerais bien que monsieur rozon alors
il fait naître façon ecce homo et breizh
comment les idées de rosanvallon de d'où
elles viennent de quel matrice
existentielle il resterait même dans mes
choix littéraires ils sont trés ils sont
très variés c'est pour cela que j'ai
pris trois livres très différents c'est
le dernier c'est un livre de claude
lefort qui s'appelle l'invention
démocratique pour une raison simple
c'est que je pense que taux de faure a
été l'équivalent de hannah arendt en
france et je pense même que sa théorie
du totalitarisme est une théorie plus
puissante que celle d' hannah arendt et
qui n'a pas la reconnaissance sociale
qui est à la hauteur de son oeuvre et
j'ai eu la chance d'être un compagnon de
route et même de bureaux de clown et le
port et on veut vraiment lui rendent
hommage
le deuxième livre c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres je dirais de livres qu'ils
apprennent à mettre de la distance entre
la vie et la société je ne partage
aucune des idées de flaubert mais ce que
j'aime dans boulevard et pécuchet
dans cette vision en quelque sorte de la
bêtise c'est l'exercice sein de la
distance vis-à-vis de soi-même
1les à midi toujours heureux l'homme qui
sait rire de lui même il n'a pas fini de
s'amuser
eh bien on peut dire aussi heureux celui
qui comprend ce qu'est la bêtise pour
essayer d'y tomber le moins souvent
possible les troisièmes c'est le lycée
françois villon le très bien le livre
françois bégaudeau il est sur la table
et je
avec vous le troisième livre c'est un
recueil épreuve exorcisme de d'henri
michaux parce que je les cite est un peu
au début de mon livre un poète parce que
je pense que la langue ça plus autre
expression reste là reste la poésie et
qu'au fond dans ce recueil de michao il
dit dans des termes qui sont absolument
puissant extraordinaire ce qu'est
l'épreuve le malheur la difficulté mais
que pour en sortir disait-il il faut
pratiquer l'exorcisme et moi j'ai voulu
montrer qu'il y avait une autre voie que
l'exorcisme c'était tout de même
d'essayer de penser de formuler des
concepts merci beaucoup bien grand
vallon de l'avoir fait d'être venu nous
en parler aujourd'hui votre livre
s'appelle notre histoire intellectuelle
et politique de 1968 à 2018 disponible
aux éditions du seuil
merci françois bégaudeau commerciaux
dernier ouvrage s'appelle en guerre
disponible aux éditions verticales on se
quitte avec une chanson comme chaque
semaine une chanson qui révèle peut-être
votre passé de rocard france à bogota
n'en a pas parlé quelques icônes comme
ça qui ont voté pour nous iggy pop lust
for life
[Musique]
oui
c'était livrez vous avec le concours du
centre national du livre
[Musique]